this image
of an american president
that's why i've been saying somebody so
weak and frail
and such a cognitive mess
america deserves better
we don't leave our fellow citizens our
fellow americans behind
we rescue our fellow americans trapped
behind enemy lines we respond to terror
attacks with overwhelming force we have
the greatest military on the face of the
earth
we strike fear into the hearts of all of
our enemies and instill confidence in
all of our allies but under biden
none of that has happened and clearly
will happen made that clear yesterday
the one thing that was clear no more
military presence we're getting out
we're sticking to the timetable and yeah
there'll be americans left behind in all
likelihood now we're suffering the
consequences of his real weaknesses in
real time mark my words with so many
trap this could all get so much worse
before it gets better and i pray that i
am wrong
our first guest tonight it comes from
the you to the u.s from northern
afghanistan his boss the so-called
president of afghanistan
reportedly fled uh the country many
weeks ago with four cars and a
helicopter full of millions and millions
of dollars of cash but my next guess is
the vice president
of afghanistan still in the country
leading the resistance against the
taliban and tonight he is pledging to
help any americans that will be left
behind ambrella soleil is with us right
now you're in the northern part
of afghanistan i understand you have a
very strong resistance that is growing
by the day i have reports on the ground
that i've confirmed
that you are leading the country you're
the de facto resistance leader of the
country in your rightful place
considering the your president left and
my question is
what would you need to ensure the safety
of our afghan allies innocent afghan
citizens and americans that will be left
behind because i want my fellow
americans brought home
safely well we need two three things to
be done and and these are doable things
and it will save the lives of americans
and it will most likely save the lives
of millions of africans number one
pakistanis
taliban and al-qaeda are celebrating the
defeat of united states it is a must for
joe biden administration to take
pakistani state accountable all the
taliban leaders who are in kabul
including haqqanis they came from
pakistan
that is number one
number two they should make it very
clear to the taliban now who are in
control of kabul
that if one more attack is carried out
it will be taliban responsible for it
because
few days back we warned the americans
that the only way for taliban to gain
control of the kabul airport
is to stage suicide attacks or attacks
and then blame it on the isis
otherwise this fiasco is not going to
end soon
so for taliban to say it is not as
taliban or the creator
of the suicide bombing
thing in afghanistan over the past 20
years they cannot become innocent
overnight
number three united states
must use it is power of convening and
power of bringing nations together
to create an alliance for peace as it
had created an alliance for war against
terrorism
and they should not abandon afghanistan
there is a lot united the state can do
today the afghans your foes and your
rivals and everybody watching
the superpowers seeming so weak that
should be averted
these are doable things we are not
asking you to re-escalate come back
militarily
we are asking united states to project
confidence
hope power
not weakness not desperation not being
seen
as a superpower on run and unable to do
anything
you know this united let me explain
something to you as defeated this is a
disaster
you need to understand something
the united states under this president
not the last president under this
president has no appetite to provide any
assistance at this point uh yesterday at
the press conference joe biden was very
clear he has no appetite to send troops
in even to save americans and even the
prospect of leaving americans behind
i can tell you that the vast
overwhelming uh massive majority of
americans find that repulsive sir
but with that said
uh i don't control the president i don't
control congress we're going to bring in
a senator and a congressman in a minute
my question to you is
specifically can you tell us how many
how many fighters you have what kind of
equipment you have what are the things
that america might be able to offer you
militarily so that you can accomplish
your mission of defeating the taliban
isis k the emergence of al qaeda and
help americans in the process that might
be left behind get home
well first of all fmr if any american
tries to take refuge in the safe haven
that we have created we will welcome
them with open arms we will provide them
protection and we will make sure
that they are safe and we will
coordinate whatever way possible with
you so that these americans will be
evacuated so panchayat valley today
is not only a valley it is the center it
is the safe haven and it is the capital
for all those who fear their lives who
are who are fearing taliban terrorists
and who are trying to get to somewhere
to feel safe so with that said
what is our strength the biggest
strength we have is our political will
which unfortunately is isn't there in
washington united the states is capable
of doing everything
but the decision which was taken to
withdraw troops from afghanistan so
abruptly was a political decision it has
hurt the feelings of so many american
service members the intelligence
community the strategic community look
i understand washington was fatigued by
paying few billion dollars and retaining
2000 troops in afghanistan
what you are seeing now
america is paying with it is dignity
with his reputation and with its
credibility
america must show will
and power and it should project hope and
confidence